hi I'm Wanda Sykes and I'm taking the
wired autocomplete interview
[Music]
[Applause]
how is hikes I'm doing quite well thank
you how to get wanda sykes hairstyle
electrical outlet Thank You thing wet it
first think it right now I have a great
stylist it's a team of people that I use
and it's called the straw set and my
hair is it's natural no perms or
anything
how long is Wanda Sykes show I believe
it was an hour I felt like days how tall
is Wanda Sykes six four
I know TV makes you look shorter no I'm
five - how old is Wanda Sykes makeup
artist my makeup artist is 72 does Wanda
Sykes does Wanda Sykes have a daughter
yes I have a daughter
thank your name is Olivia does Wanda
Sykes sing yes not great at it though
but I do enjoy it does Wanda Sykes have
a brother yes I have a brother his name
is Harry does Wanda Sykes have a sister
no not a real sister I mean I don't mean
like that I don't have a sister but I
have a bunch of sorority sisters hey
girls
did Wanda Sykes ever host SNL no I know
go figure
Wanda Sykes children yes Wanda Sykes
funniest moments a love well beyond the
Chris Rock Show curb the enthusiasm and
the new adventures of old Christine
working with that cast and Julia Louie
Dreyfus was just so much fun I miss
thing Wanda Sykes
Bojack yes I did an episode I did a
voice the character a therapist and Issa
Rae we played a couple it was fun was
Wanda Sykes or Jefferson no that was
Marla Gibbs guys we're talking like back
in the 70s come on oh that one hurt what
Wanda Sykes
what did Wanda Sykes play in oh my god
so many things
eebee film a lot what is Wanda Sykes
doing now well Wanda Sykes is
entertaining you a Wanda Sykes is
touring I'm touring working on Netflix
special excited about that
what is Wanda Sykes real name Wanda
Sykes why would I change that name
that's an awesome name
come on what does Wanda Sykes use on her
hair the blood of Jesus no I boil like a
Moroccan oil that's usually my go-to
Wanda Sykes what happened what happened
I don't know I guess like I I got kind
of famous what happened that I thought
miss Sykes that was my last comedy
special I did four epics epics EP i-x
but okay is Wanda Sykes is Wanda Sykes
related to Brenda Sykes no but I used to
tell that lie when I was a kid because
she was the only Sykes that was on TV is
Wanda Sykes related to Tanisha Sykes
who's Tanisha Sykes
sorry Tunisia is Tony Cox related to
Wanda Sykes we're not related but love
your work is Wanda Sykes in Red Dead
Redemption no I'm pretty sure not in
that I don't know that one I'm sorry
it's Wanda Sykes employed by ABC not
anymore not anymore my friends who Wanda
Sykes who is Wanda Sykes hairstylist
I have Lisa devote she's the one who's
72 I also have Larry Sims he he knows
pants he wears a lot of hats and NEBOSH
a-- johnson she's in New York so takes a
village to do this
who is Wanda Sykes partner my wife is
Alex Sykes my business partner is Paige
Herbert's who does Wanda Sykes play in
Rio maybe a buzzard I'm a bird that's
it's I'm Chloe the goose Buzzard goose
go figure
who does Wanda Sykes play on blackish
I've played Daphne lead up I'm the
ex-wife of the partner the Lido part
that you never see
where was wanda sykes born I was born in
Portsmouth Virginia where is Wanda Sykes
right now in Los Angeles in a building
in a room doing this
what did wanda sykes die oh sweet Jesus
really silly honey I'm here I'm not dead
come on geez
when did Wanda Sykes get married October
2009 that's Wanda Sykes stop googling me
what was the dead one come on I need to
tweet more why won't you google things
like you know why why didn't Wanda Sykes
make the sexiest person alive or like
how does Wanda Sykes keep her body in
such great shape how can I get my skin
to look like Wanda Sykes stuff like that
how come Wanda Sykes is in a Marvel
superhero what's going on with that she
can fly